three-time all-star Sean Casey Major
League Baseball Network analyst he'll be
part of MLB network's all-star game
coverage beginning today at 3:00 Eastern
Nationals Park MLB tonight airing live
before and after the all-star game
your first all-star game oh yeah who did
you want to meet oh my gosh
well it was 1999 I was 25 and I was
literally like I thought I'd like won a
contest you know and like Piazza's right
next to me McGwire all those guys yeah I
think I think I wanted to hang out with
McGwire and I wanted to know the Randy
Johnson wasn't gonna kill me like I was
like I wanted to humanize him you know I
mean so he was not mighty like hey nice
to meet you at his son there I'm like
okay I feel better about facing him now
because he just said hi to me you know I
mean but but one of the coolest stories
of that time was you an all century team
comes out right and then Ted Williams
comes out right like it was Fenway Park
and what Pedro didn't want stuff but
we're walking up to Ted Williams when he
came to throw out the first pitch and I
get it I get a pat on my shoulder and I
turn around its George Brett because
he's we're all walking in so that all
century team comes with the players and
I'm like he's like hey man hey I just
want to reduce myself George Brett man I
love you love your swing I literally I
couldn't say anything else he got was a
billion guys a total loser you know me
so but I was one of the coolest moments
my life at that time George Brett pat me
on the shoulder I was like fact that
this guy even knows who I am is
unbelievable did you get autographs oh
my gosh I crushed him I got great I got
I always felt like I was a fan I was
like they're gonna sit them I'm trickin
these guys and soon they're gonna send
me down so I'm gonna get as many
autographs is I can't I just yeah be
your hitting 350 or I know but still you
never know we're gonna hit 210 and like
get tossed at it right so I I literally
I literally first base couldn't have
been better for me because I I just put
in the memorabilia room that I've been
waiting to put in for years right and I
like I counted everything up a hundred
and eighty bats
side I have like 400 baseballs like I
mean who does that is ridiculous it's a
cool room now I collect it all myself
but this how I collect it like holding
guys are I remember like I remember one
of the coolest bats I have is Tony Gwynn
right so 32 probably 29 it's got
tennis grip on it right but I remember
holding them on to be like hey man any
chance you could send a bat over to me
and he was like what's going on first
place they'd get their lead I'm like hey
I was like I know you're 15 years in the
league this is my second and I don't
know how long I'm gonna be here so if
you could just send a ball to banner
over that'd be great yeah remember
running into McGwire one time like hey
what's up Big Mac going the cage like
hey you might send in a bat over to me
everyone's doing it you know so it's
cool so I have a lot of cool stuff that
I collected just because what's the one
thing though that if you got to get out
of the house that's that's your grabbing
one you know what the one thing that I
love Pearl Jam in 2013 isn't that funny
well the twin batter probably to get
that and then you know Vetter and I were
hanging out one night at the the
Clemente Museum in Pittsburgh you ever
been there no in in Pittsburgh you guys
got to go it's called engine house 25
this guy Dwayne reader has an
unbelievable Clemente museum and there's
a winery downstairs so Pearl Jam was
opening up Friday night this is Tuesday
night and we're hanging out just having
some wine smoking the cigar and just
talking you know talking baseball and he
was like hey what do you want to hear
Friday night I was like oh really all
right cool ask me what I want to hear
Friday night so I go into a bunch of
things he pulls out edy pulls out a pic
right six songs on it right and I'm like
oh that's cool so then we go to the show
on Friday he plays all the songs asked
and play and after the show he's like
hey I you here's the pic from Tuesday
night so I don't know why but I'm
getting that pic it's in the frame but
I'm gonna take it out pick out if
there's a fire time I'm out of there
okay but how do you hook up with any
better to begin with you know what 2003
we're in we're playing the Cubs six
games to go in the season it's been like
the one of the worst seasons ever
everyone's on the dl Jason LaRue and I
are the only two guys that have finished
the season right so like when you're 30
games out and there's six games to go
you're literally you're literally
running the sprints before the game
going how am I gonna make it through six
more games I don't
I can do it right so after the game
would come in and there's a guy sitting
there with short blond hair I got the
time I guess he had dyed his hair and it
was and he was sitting with Carnell and
jose cardenal was was Ed's like Idol
growing up in Chicago and Carnell was
our our first base coach one of the
greatest coaches I had just such a great
guy and met him that night he ended up
playing a song for us in the clubhouse
we asked him which is so nice
we stayed afterwards and everyone hung
out and and that's how I first met him
and then and then really kind of met him
again a no wait with Theo Epstein did
you guys you know chop it up late night
your your teams were you guys partiers
uh I mean not real big partiers but we'd
go to the hotel bar you know have a
couple of pops after the game and just
you know reminisce
you know I I don't know if those guys if
guys nowadays still dude I'm sure they
do but you know some of the best times
were in the club you know staying in the
clubhouse maybe having a having a pop
and just talking baseball you know and
just did you ever have one of those Kruk
moments didn't Kruk didn't they play
wiffle ball with the club ease and he
wasn't gonna play the next day at
Wrigley and he stayed up all night and
he was told he had the day off drinking
beer yeah you had to play I think he
went but he stayed all night in the
clubhouse drinking beer with the club
he's playing wiffle ball I thinks he's
got the day off you know you didn't have
one of those moments that he had with
Randy Johnson in the all-star game where
basically said look I just I don't hurt
me I don't wanna be here I when I first
faced Johnson like yeah I was I was
legitimately scared and it was you know
it was and I you know I remember I
remember like battle and twos like my
first about to to or like foul foul foul
foul and then next you know like Randy
Johnson he's like I don't know what he
was thinking like he walks up ten feet
from the plate like what's he doing he
grabs the ball looks at me I'm like I
just got the next picture like I like
choked up rolled over the second I was
like thank God about like six 1193 mono
or slide or 100 miles an hour
from behind you big mullet that's
intimidating I mean you're used to
seeing a guy who might be six-three
six-four six-five oh yeah you don't mind
that 611 lefty I'm like telling Jack
McKean I think killing there had to be
guys left-handers who had the Randy
Johnson flew right oh yeah you couldn't
you hundred percent yeah you weren't
gonna play that next day no doubt about
it is there is there a guy nowadays
where somebody would like sale
Chris Sale I mean who wants to face that
right it looks like he's just like he
really letting it eat just fear is just
with conviction you don't mean so I love
watching sale he's watching Scherzer
yeah you know what like guys had just
pound the strike zone
how much place don't waste time and here
it is it's nasty in the zone it's late
movement I'm coming right at you you
know it I know it you know it's like a
Retton one-on-one wrestling match right
well what's the fastest pitch you think
he ever faced
Joella Zumaya in yeah was like one aback
in the devil when he was with the Tigers
it was like 100 I think 103 and I was
like okay so if I throw you 98 yeah and
I throw you 103
yeah is there that much of a difference
it's well my view through 98 and 93 I
mean that's like 93 looks like poop soup
98 looks like gasoline so then we go to
103 we're like okay that's a different
ballgame I've never seen that but what's
poop soup I'll poop soups just like when
guys are just laying it in there you
know you come back the Duggar like
what's the guy guys like this guy's got
poop yeah we're gonna get him out in the
third one hundred percent put a string
together a couple mocks boom he's a
degree so he's he's throwing salad yeah
he's like the 4/5 star that's just but
you flopping it up there but you face
Jamie Moyer right oh yeah Oh Jamie Moore
I face even more when he was like 65
years old I think it's I think it's like
here's what the Phillies and stills
thrown the same but it was unbelievable
because he would throw a 79 Morrow
heater what not a heater not here but
and his changeup was so good it's not
believing like I think I don't think I
got a hit huh and you what you walk up
back to the dugout you're like how am i
hitting this guy he's like his change it
was so good like you know had 11 miles
to 1011 more difference and it was so
nasty that his seven team on our heater
would like look pretty hard if we had an
open draft for pitchers right now right
you got him for the next five years
yeah who you got open draft for pitchers
um well I gotta go with Scherzer right
for the next five years
oh yeah okay he's an animal he's a
pitcher however long you want okay Chris
Sale good right I got those two okay ah
sure since 33 that's all right he's
gonna pitch until he's 38 um
GERD Cole okay I think he's a horse I
think I think Cole's just getting better
Severino Oh Severino 100% he's 24 yeah
he's yeah you're right
he's very good yeah there's four who
else you got dan syndergaard no I like
degrom I like degrom degrom is the
ground was filthy do you think he should
be starting the game oh I don't know I
mean I it's unfortunate that he's had
this good he could be the siyoung winner
in the net there's no doubt about
because there's no run support right but
he's he's another one of those guys I'm
gonna pound the strike zone right and I
don't waste time don't waste time
anybody that has listen I really think
that the best hitters and the best best
pitchers they make their money that last
five you know five feet three feet
whatever it is in the zone where where
things are cutting you know sinking like
anybody has great movement in the zone
any great hitter that can wait late make
decisions a little bit later I think
those are the best players and when you
see like a guy like the Grom sure they
pound the strike zone with good movement
and they can you know kind of pepper
pepper both corners did you ever suspect
a pitcher cheating yeah sure yeah doctor
in the ball yeah I'm sure there's no
doubt about now how different is it like
what do you see when you see that
somebody's just done it the movement
that it's so big anybody that has really
big movement sometimes you got a
question who who had big movement ah let
you questioned
I don't know you're out of it no I'm not
I'm still in it this is gonna be
everybody just you just Sean Casey
thinks so so cheap give me a hint no I'm
not telling you Dan is he still in the
game
no Mike Mussina not the moose now I
never thought that I faced him one time
okay he was good hmm
[Laughter]
I'm not talking did you but you say
anything to the catcher no you just know
understand but how do they cut the ball
who knows I mean you know maybe there's
something that get a little phone to
glow follow you no okay a lot of guys I
mean I don't think it's necessary
cheating I think you know the pine tar
thing you know pictures using pine tar
what the Gil I think but are you okay
with that I am I am I'd rather have that
you had grip yeah I didn't have a grip
it definitely helps him I think it does
help with your grip too you know give it
a little bit more spin rate or whatever
but I don't know I think a lot of guys
are gonna well remember Kenny Rutland I
don't know I didn't know I'd say that
Kenny Rogers no card but but but is that
the guy you're talking about cuz I was
on his team house I keep doing it
because you're first base yeah oh yeah
so you're aware of something if somebody
comes to first base right did anybody
ever say you know that dude's cheap I
mean probably best conversation you ever
had at first base oh man have had some
great conversations um Lance Berkman was
just always a great conversation because
he was he wasn't going anywhere and he
was he's fat Elvis yeah no no yeah he
could rake though but he we'd have some
we have a great time at first base and
longer the bat would go would be great
oh you know what Henry Rodriguez my
rookie year never tell you this story so
it was like the whole thing we're like
you know I'm excited to be there it's
1998 like I said I'm asking him for an
autograph there's like
this guy so rod the loans on the mound I
was my first it was like I was three
weeks in the big leagues and and so I
never been with Ron Valon right so Henry
Rodriguez gets it lead off and I'm like
hey a man it's really cool like it's so
cool when you Homer and they like throw
the O'Henry bars on the field and he
turns music thanks man right when he
turns me wrong so sorry did you ever do
the hidden ball trick no never did it
never did saw Matt when I first got
caught up with the Indians I saw Matt
Williams do it and get I can remember
who he got he would he went over to the
3rd was like hey excuse me man I just
want to be seen that work and then they
drilled a mix like Matt got up there
next about boom right now I was like I'm
not trying that again I was telling out
later so how's brother Mark Wright is a
monster like Al's a monster right he's a
big dude and Mark lighters a monster too
so my rookie I don't know why I go back
to my rookie year all these things
happen but Scott Sullivan had hit Scott
Rolen like twice once at rolling at home
or twice so here I go it's like again my
first month in the big leagues and I'm
leading off the next inning and Mark
Leiter comes in throwing like 97 I'm
like and he's a monster so I'm like I'm
definitely wearing one right here right
first pitch boom right in the ribs I
just put my head down like heroes with
the first page you know trying to just
hustle down at first like hopefully mark
later didn't look at me wrong to charge
me and you want to cry yeah I was that
hurt don't rub it was like don't rub him
total rubbish got 96 right in the ribs
you got seams oh yeah see with a
baseball see oh yeah so so awesome how
many stolen bases did you have oh I
think I had like 17 bags so you played
too well how many years that outfalls
he'd play 12 Paulie plays yeah yeah he
Sean Casey 12 seasons 18 stolen bases
that's
one and a half stolen bases per year yes
and I had four I had for one year how
about that guy's one of the hey we're
these like double steals you were the
back end of a double steal or something
I think 12 of them were back in double
no what happened was what was great was
whether was the back of the double still
they throw like everyone's throw in a
second this is great
were you always a slowest guy on your
team I kind of was man I it was just
it's so frustrating cuz I would work on
my speed all the time and I'd be like so
good then I get in the game hit one of
the gap and just turn into like this guy
I'm like ice skating in quicksand it's
like I'm phenomenal do you find yourself
defending the game more and more now
that you're out and how people view it
and you know is it America's pastime and
what needs to be done and there's all
home runs and strikeouts do you find it
I mean I still think it's the greatest
game going and I I love baseball I love
you know there's so much passion for the
game I think you know there's a listen
look at the all-star game there's a lot
of there's a lot of good characters out
there a lot of good talent there's a lot
of guys that can hit the ball you know a
long way I mean strikeouts are up I
think the game is different that way I
think that you know I think back when I
was playing if you struck out a hundred
times a year people always striking out
a hundred times year you're embarrassed
yeah and now guys are striking out 200
and you're getting 20 mil you know I
mean so I think just the mentality of
players right but how would you be like
you're not a home run hitting guy yeah
but you would be I think I think a guy
like myself I think they're starting to
realize the value of guys that don't
strikeout guys to put the ball in play
guys that can get on base guys that you
know that get the line move and I think
the more teams if you watch the teams
that have won the World Series they've
had they've had they're not huge
strikeout teams you know because in the
postseason you're gonna get faced good
pitching and the teams that have lineups
that can get the ball that can get the
line move and can get on base and hit a
little bit those are the teams that win
it's always good to see you man you're
the best a lot of fun the best guys are
too man appreciate you guys happen he's
known as the mayor who gave you that
nickname Bill Mose yellow and this Mike
Kirby when I was in the Cape Cod League
in 1994 the like
it looks like you're lobbying for votes
I'm like I am so they start calling me
the mayor and it's kind of stuck hey
Sean Casey part of MLB network's
all-star game coverage beginning live
today at 3:00 Eastern from nationals
part you're gonna make up on oh yeah I
like that
yeah MLB tonight I love makeup I would
this face I got to have it before and
why didn't you wear some today fine
because I just came here and hanging out
with you I don't know where's the makeup
artist here dan Patrick Joe does have
any making she was back there how about
somebody tell me talking to Johnny Bench
about Pete Rose and how good they were
in the 70s and on stuff before and after
the all-star game MLB tonight with Sean
and company thanks for stopping by oh
man close up shop here in DC after this
in the Dan Patrick show for more Dan
Patrick show to the audience Channel 239
on DirecTV or download the Dan Patrick
show app
[Music]